and we're following breaking news from
the Middle East where a series of
sabotage attacks are targeting critical
oil supplies the attacks are reportedly
aimed at oil tankers owned by Saudi
Arabia and other countries they come
amid warnings from the US about a
growing threat from Iran MTS tyub is
monitoring these developments from
London MT has good morning good morning
we got a really tense situation in the
Persian Gulf right now according to the
United Arab Emirates four vessels in the
Persian Gulf were in their words
sabotage Saudi Arabia also says that two
of its vessels were also targeted now
this is one of the vessels that was
apparently sabotage but it shows no
signs of damage however a spokesperson
for the Saudi own Bari
oil company confirmed that a vessel it
manages had been hit by an explosion no
one was injured and the ship is stable
we've also just learned a Norwegian
registered tanker is in the area was
also damaged by a floating object what's
going on now follows warnings from the
Trump administration that Iran or its
quote proxies are allegedly threatening
American interests in the Gulf Iran said
the attacks were quote worrying and
called for a full investigation of a
possible what it described as a
conspiracy orchestrated by ill-wishers
whatever the case the tensions here have
only risen since President Trump
withdrew from the 2015 nuclear deal
brokered between Tehran and world powers
John Kim T has tie up in London thank
you